is a senior nurse with over 20 years
experience
from today her colleagues in the NHS
will start to receive a pay rise and a
one-off bonus worth around 2 000 pounds
on average
but there will be no bonus for Denise
because her contract is outsourced I
don't understand why my teams do not get
the pay rise and equal treatment to the
rest of the NHS they feel like they are
basically second-class citizens within
Healthcare
Amela worked through the pandemic she
sends money to support her family in the
Philippines and the bonus could have
been used to buy a ticket home for the
first time in years and during the
pandemic that we didn't manage to go
home and you know just like everybody
else that we lost our loved ones and
didn't manage to go
okay I lost both my parents during
printing
and you haven't been back
my name is Harriet I'm one of the nurse
practitioners as you know how can I help
you today over a million eligible
workers on the agenda for change
contract will receive the pay Boost
that pay award includes a one-off NHS
backlog bonus in recognition of the work
staff did during the pandemic and are
doing now to bring down that record
waiting list but nobody could argue with
that clinical staff working in Social
Enterprise aren't playing an equally
vital role
in a letter to the health secretary NHS
organizations and employers warn of an
impact to patient services if they are
to fund the bonuses
the uplift represents significant sums
and if unfunded along with inflationary
pressures will result in a reduction in
service provision and vacancy freezes
they are therefore having to consider
the potential impact on patient services
and the viability of their organizations
they want to and need to pay the staff
what they deserve this means they might
be asked to find one two three four five
million pounds they aren't going to be
able to do that they've reinvested their
profits in their communities the pay
award is in recognition of the
dedication and professionalism of health
workers and staff here say that should
be without exception Ashish Joshi Sky
News